so from the start this this is no good
you need
always to be about 10 cm minimum AC cost
of
Swords we're doing weapons and yet we're
not doing weapons it's very
contradictory we must be accurate with
the weapons and yet we must remove the
thought of you know killing or cutting
or anything like that so but when I'm
here if I tap this would come from Kendo
so we then go back
to so this is why on a lot of YouTube
you you'll see
people doing this and you'll hear this
this is very rude because in Japan in in
the UK we might say oh this is a nice
gei in Japan this would be a very very
rude thing to do touch somebody's gee
you know it be impolite so it's the same
thing when you when you come with the
can you start doing this you've lost
your zans you're not being polite so so
always keep a small space per 5
cm and not this not this not this
unevenness so this is all about the
respect of of our
level he
isach I am UK tach UK always the
receiver when there nag and UK it's
because UK is receiving n technique so
here I wait because I should be mentally
connected not sort of like waiting
waiting for him to move so when so I
should be so when he's the first one to
move I then s like as if I'm tied
together with
string move with
him he has to move and then I move
I must getting there before get
slightly TI must be able to be seen by
him I must out I
must give this a little push and make it
come there I watch him he cuts first I
come over here and I cut the wrist so
this is where it's Marshall and this is
where it's um weapons so I the
wrist in the sword score he would take
his right hand off take it
over and bring it back again to cut me
so this is where the weapons comes in if
I do this this is an advanced practice
because we're tied together and we're
doing it as a muui not as a weapons Bas
it all right so this is where you'll see
the variations when cyto sensor used to
do this is because he's tied together
with this person's spirit and then you
go into the higher levels of
understanding so for basic you cover the
wrist again about uh 7 to 10
cm you lift it off slightly to his
elbow it's it can be like a flick but
it's just enough to say to him I'm
releasing you you come like a u shape
under here you don't turn this anymore s
used to say don't turn it abnormally and
make your wrists difficult so you just
turn it enough you then make him go back
as he sees
that he will now step forward and try to
cut me and that's what puts it deep
through his neck deep through his neck a
lot of people
from this a lot
of one two like that and they Stu
so so you've got to realize the person
is not an idiot you know he's not going
to just let you do that off like that
and you so so you slice the head
off you now remove the
body you it looks like this and this but
it's actually
well